IN THE MEANTIME BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE WE GO.
THE WHITE HOUSE TRIES TO GET
THE SOUTHERN BORDER UNDER
CONTROL FOX NEWS WITH A LOOK AT
HOW CARTELS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE CHAOS AND
MAKING A TON OF MONEY.
BORDER OFFICIALS TRY TO STOP
DRUGS AND SMUGGLED MIGRANTS
FROM THE COUNTRY.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY WE HAVE SOMEONE HERE
TODAY.
STATISTICS FROM OPERATION LONE
STAR.
TEXAS ALONE, CRIMINAL ARRESTS
700.
MARIJUANA SEIZURES 5,000 POUNDS.
COCAINE AND METH, FIREARMS,
CURRENCY SEIZURES MORE THAN A
MILLION.
IT IS ALL THERE, LIEUTENANT.
ALL COMING OUR WAY.
>> GOOD MORNING, BILL.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
YOU’RE CORRECT.
NUMBERS DON’T LIE AND THEY
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN ILLEGAL CROSSING AS
WELL AS ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AS YOU
SEE THERE WITH THOSE STATS.
WEAPONS, DRUGS, CURRENCY,
PURSUIT.
THERE IS A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
CRIMINAL ASPECTS TAKING PLACE
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER RIGHT
NOW.
>> Bill: ONE REPORT YOU SEIZED
$11 MILLION WORTH OF DRUGS IN A
48 HOUR PERIOD.
IT BLOWS THE MIND.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU HEARD VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS OVER
THE WEEKEND.
A SAMPLE FROM WHAT SHE SAID ON
CNN ON SUNDAY.
>> WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN IS THE
DIPLOMATIC WORK WE’VE BEEN
ENGAGED IN INCLUDING MY CALLS
TO THE PRESIDENT OF MEXICO, THE
PRESIDENT OF GUATEMALA.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE SOLVED
OVERNIGHT.
UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THEY PULLED OUT
ESSENTIALLY A LOT OF WHAT HAD
BEEN THE CONTINUUM OF WORK AND
IT ESSENTIALLY CAME TO A STAND
STILL.
>> Bill: LIEUTENANT, WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF THAT ANSWER?
>> BILL, WHAT I CAN SAY ON THAT
IS SHE IS CORRECT AS FAR AS IT
WON’T BE AN OVERNIGHT SOLUTION
BUT IT DOES TAKE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT TO HELP OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS.
THE STATE OF TEXAS WILL ANSWER
THE CALL AND WE ALWAYS DO.
IT TAKES SUPPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND COME SEE
IT FOR YOURSELF.
COME SEE IT FOR YOURSELF AND
SPEAK TO THE GREAT MEN AND
WOMEN WORKING THE FRONT LINES
WHO SEE IT DAY IN AND DAY OUT
WHO RISK THEIR LIVES TO PROTECT
THE BORDER FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND FOR THE CITIZENS OF TEXAS.
>> Bill: WE FOUND IN OUR FOX
POLLING U.S. BORDER SECURITY
COMPARED TO TWO YEARS AGO.
YOU CAN’T SEE THIS, SIR, I’LL
READ IT TO YOU.
IS IT BETTER OR WORSE OR THE
SAME?
46% SAY NOW IT IS WORSE THAN
JUNE OF 2018.
KAMALA HARRIS SAID SHE WOULD GO
TO CENTRAL AMERICA IN JUNE.
WHAT’S WRONG WITH NOW?
>> RIGHT NOW, BILL, I CAN TELL
YOU FROM SPEAKING WITH THE MEN
AND WOMEN WORKING THE FRONT
LINES OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS,
THIS YEAR BY FAR ANY PREVIOUS
YEARS HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OF ILLEGAL CROSSINGS
AND CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
THE NUMBERS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES AND THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK WITH OPERATION
DAY IN AND DAY OUT CAN SPEAK ON
IT AS WELL.
>> Bill: LIEUTENANT, GOOD LUCK
DOWN THERE.
YOU NEED A LOT OF HELP.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
FROM THE STATE OF TEXAS WITH AN
ISSUE THAT IS TOO LARGE TO
MANAGE NOW GIVEN THE WAY IT HAS
GONE OVER THE PAST THREE WEEKS.
>> Dana: I CAN’T FOR THE LIFE
OF ME UNDERSTAND THE FIRST
WOMAN VICE PRESIDENT NOT
SEIZING THIS IMMIGRATION BUT TO
DRIVE ON LOTS OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
YOU CAN TRAVEL SAFELY.
EVERYBODY IS DOING IT.
SHE HAS A PRIVATE PLANE AND
PROTOCOLS AND ABILITY TO GO AND
DO SOMETHING.
I JUST FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
REALLY MISSING AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE.
>> Bill: AS WE SAID LAST HOUR
YOU CAN FLY TO AN AIRPORT, HAVE
A MEETING IN A HANGAR, COME
BACK AND BE PERFECTLY SAFE WITH
COVID.
WITH REGARD TO THE DRUGS COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY A BIG PROBLEM.
YOU CAN SEE THAT DRUG CARTELS A
LOT OF MONEY AND POWER THEY
HAVE KNOW HOW TO RUN THIS
BUSINESS.
AND THEY WILL GET THE LINES OF
TRANSPORT FOR THESE ILLEGAL
DRUGS ACROSS THE BORDER AND
INTO AMERICAN CITIES QUICKER
THAN YOU KNOW.
THEY KNOW HOW TO MAKE THE MONEY
AND THEY ARE DOING IT RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: NATIONAL REVIEW TODAY
ONLINE NICOLE BISCH YOP AND
CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY.
THEY WRITE ABOUT HOW THE
CARTELS HAVE BASICALLY SEIZED
THE MOMENT AND WE’RE NOT, WHICH
IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
MOVING ON NOW AS PRESIDENT
BIDEN COMPLETES HIS FIRST 100
DAYS IN OFFICE CONGRESSWOMAN